the whiskey X Festival is more than 60
whiskeys infused with music style and
chefs it takes place Saturday at the
Cosmopolitan and here to tell us more is
Fedora bonucci with the Cosmopolitan of
Las Vegas welcome to the show thank you
for having me how do you find 60 plus
whiskeys those whiskey is a really
popular drink right now and there are a
lot of Boutique Brands out there and we
put a we curated a whole group of them
uh and this is for the person who's they
like whiskey maybe they want to learn a
little more about it and they can come
to the event and Sample and talk to the
distillers and learn a little bit more
about stuff and compare and contrast so
this is great for the whiskey lovers but
so like myself who's new to Whiskey it's
an educational experience exactly it's a
lifestyle experience an educational
experience you come one ticket all the
samplings involved included we also have
haircuts from the bar yeah let's bring
it down because we have we have styles
so you guys be doing haircuts there and
beer it's a full lifestyle event there's
cigars available there's haircuts
there's food from the Cosmopolitan uh
we've got a bunch of the outlets like
chicken sandwiches from Hattie B's all
the all the greatest hits because you
guys the Cosmopolitan have some of the
best restaurants in Las Vegas what are
some of the restaurants that'll be out
there on Saturday honey bees will have a
chicken sandwich SDK is going to have
them going out there there's a an egg
roll from from uh I'm forgetting it yeah
and uh and uh um Mama fuku's gonna have
our pork buns which are my favorite
actually this is a huge lifestyle event
you mentioned cigars we're out there
smoking cigars it's poolside stunning
view entertainment music Saint Paul and
the Broken Bones Soul band they played
last year at the same event amazing I
suggest everyone comes out and take that
take a listen do you have is there so so
the whiskey is included in the price you
watch each Booth you're trying different
whiskeys you're talking to the people
behind the whiskeys and learning about
it is there a plan of attack when you go
out there on Saturday night or just
start start
there's there's two tickets available
there's a VIP ticket which will allow
you to get in an hour earlier so you can
have a little bit more time with the
distillers and learn a little more or
there's the regular ticket starts at
seven o'clock I suggest you pace
yourself 60 whiskeys it's a lot of
drinking there's a lot of whiskeys and
then you're going you do haircuts like
you said and how much are the haircuts
haircuts are included so free haircuts
on Saturday is there some kind of waiver
because if I do maybe five shots of
whiskey I'm like shave it all up I don't
care anymore what we do have free water
available so okay
this is awesome what time does it start
on Saturday it's six o'clock uh doors
are at six there's like I said the VIP
ticket and doors at seven for the G8
someone's watching right now do you
suggest buying the tickets in advance or
something you get them I think it's
something you should buy in advance
there's still some available you can go
on
cosmopolitanlasvegas.com and check out
all the information we have online I
love it Fedora the weather's gonna be
perfect on Saturday night it's gonna be
a great event thank you for joining us
Jillian over to you thank you